hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the adventures
markiplier and Jojo so here we go into
the tower because that's exactly where I
want to be with my lovely friend
hey yo Joe so after the aggravation of
the last part I'm hoping that we're
gonna get back into the dark and dreary
portions of this game because that is
where I had the best one oh really I'm
not in a good situation
whatever that didn't you please let it
do it better than okay oh that's good
honest missing is good too
Bhupati I meant that hurts doughnut now
I'm gonna freeze you I guess oh okay
it's like chopping down a tree a really
disgusting gross living tree
I guess streets of living I don't want
to save this tree okay I guess that'd
work
thank you
maybe I can combo this was like an
explosive bolt maybe
okay that did not work what does this do
whoa
blinds yeah oh that is good I guess I
got these it's kind of good hey you
blind it again so I can hit you right in
the face with did that feel good okay
God God the scope does not help I'm out
of bolts
I have to
then a little bit of a mini-boss there
except mega boss it could be full of
them everywhere else is full of them and
you're full of it
so thanks for the help Jojo you're the
best ok those boxes can't be broken
I'm sure that I missed some other
goodies there now is an appropriate time
to take a breather there okay so my
frustration is now over so now I'm gonna
be totally calm and collected this is
more like it wait what's this huh
oh that's the same point somewhere must
be up here what is that sound
so that elevator is kind of broken under
someone's Oh a dead body how lovely
thanks juni goo I need to freshen up a
little bit don't dog don't go in this
room by the way just give me a little
bit of privacy I enjoy your company but
any better
all right give me more turn the story on
me and Mira a month since Mira and I
were married and you little Lily are the
result of our love getting pregnant
before marriage okay I can't wait for
two months to pass so that I can finally
meet you oh you're not born yet oh okay
but I must admit that I'm scared I've
faced countless dangerous in my job and
knowing that I'm gonna be a dad is the
scariest thing of all I promise to love
you and to protect you with every fiber
of my being as long as I am in this
world I will enter this stage of my life
the same way I do every important task
with a heart full full with a full heart
and the desire to do the best I can just
know that your mother and I love you
already and cannot wait to welcome you
into this sometimes harsh world that's
really sweet and I feel like something
bad is going to result from that so
happy times probably not is where the
tragic backstory comes in I'm guessing
okay then Oh
new photos am I supposed to look at them
because the box is gone I did not find
another map fragment yet there might
have been one sitting around somewhere
in that labyrinth that I was trying to
fight everyone in but then I died where
I didn't even die it was all JoJo's
fault there might have been a key there
might have been everything I have no key
no Matt Fraction
it's a sad life I live I want to succeed
in the game and yet Jojo he holds me
back I would like to delete games up
time to start deleting yes I'm sure
this is gonna take a while and yes let
me delete more please oh this is gonna
be huh okay good enough I guess why do
they have a limit of save slots why in
any game today have limited slave slots
because we have big hard drive now even
consoles have hard drives built into
them they don't need limited save slots
it's it's not important to have limited
safe Lots it's not necessary
whatever I'm gonna finally do this thing
that I meant to do was upgrade that only
goes to 36 but that'll hey that's like
20% increase yay I can do math I took
lots of math courses I took almost
enough math persons to have a minor in
math oh well that's that's engineering
for you
everything's math a whole bunch of math
everywhere you go that's where the
practical applications of methodists
have you still not burned this guy yet
no I gotta use my matches got a bum
matches from me I am out of shotgun I
have pistol left I need to craft up I
need to craft more let's see the charged
bolts were nice but they're expensive
standard bolts I have no parts I didn't
know that I was out of parts oh I guess
so all right then well I guess I'm boned
on that one so what else can I do
oh okay that looked good
I'm glad that happened thank you for
blocking out my screen for a second
thing well I'm completely out of bolts
then I have nothing I am not doing so
good well they did just throw a minibus
at me so I'm assuming they're gonna
understand that I might be a little low
on everything if the game design was
relatively good which so far it has been
I mean I haven't been faced with
impossible situations they have been
challenging yes and fun to be honest but
you know I'm hoping they don't throw
anything else at me Joe Joe Joe think it
minutes okay I don't like that they used
to resonate almost like someone's toying
with us almost huh done Joe Joe Joe Joe
Joe Joe
hang in there just a little further yeah
okay unhhhh woman one moment go okay let
me just heal him up because this keeps
bugging me to do it I have no idea how
I'm healing him I think I'm just giving
a little smooch little kiss here and
there on the cheek on the forehead some
other places that I don't appreciate but
it
[Applause]
okay thanks for with that we can take no
that's not Jojo Jojo
oh boy Jojo what is it with you and
falling off bridges
[Music]
okay you're not gonna kill him it seemed
like you wanted oh no you're gonna put
him in the guillotine I gotta get to him
no no no no no no no no no no no no not
gonna happen no I care about Joe Joe no
matter what I say I care if I need to
snipe you bastards is that what's going
on
give me yes three bullets is all I need
more than enough come on come on come on
give it you gimme gimme-gimme-gimme got
it okay one down who else wants some
you want some lady just give me a good
shot you're not lady come on well I won
that competition
I wonder if Joe Joe died if that would
have been the end of Joe Joe Joe hey Joe
no need to worry well if you were fine
you could have gotten up at any moment
Oh see you end yes thank you thank you
for the convenient plank of wood the
exact size and length that we need oh
you're so strong why did the character
that look like me have to be such a
burden of he real gentle gentle like it
you should just let them what huh matter
of time
it's better this way
what the [ __ ] yeah
but that's no good oh they can't do
anything because now there's a big hole
in the bridge Thank You Jojo you're
smarter than I think you all wait know
what just take off the wooden plank okay
I guess logic is not a very strong point
of this game yeah oh no wait Joe's gonna
do that I have to do all this
okay I'm gonna miss everything I'm the
worst Joe John the Sun
well this is going swimmingly
Thank You whoa okay so I don't need to
shoot him at all I just need to lead
them to the dynamite come on give me
mama come on hit me
I'm gonna do it hit me don't hit Jojo
take that moment Jojo but if I'm going
this way I'm gonna go say hi to her hey
buddy
okay
[Applause]
really okay speed a little bit of a
breather thank you good back hey you got
a dynamite things ya think about
dynamite man
but but oh come on now it's right on his
face he blew himself up you deserve that
can't even say that it's not funny
totally funny okay
okay anything for me oh just in time
Jojo I did not have a bullet left I just
want to say that right now I did not I
need first day you all right
he just said he's a first date yeah
little bit of a contradictory statement
there slurp up my love that's what heals
you just concentrated liquid love not
like don't be gross nope thank you thank
you thank you thank you thank you
reload reload reload cuz knowing this
game there's gonna be a lot more stuff
to be done not out of the woods yet well
good more boxes to smash yay
screw property hope everyone in this
poor town never buys more again cuz they
know I'm just gonna come rampaging
through
oh wait that's familiar there's a
picture of that the weeping angel statue
this looks like some kind of a market
place oh good it looks deserted just
like everywhere else mmm you got to keep
moving so if I smash that thing it's
gonna have a whole bunch of keys in it
because that's what I'm talk
right the statues the keys that's what I
believe maybe just throw a grenade at it
I might be able to get all of the
goodies out of it okay maybe not what
the hell is going with that I was a rope
okay thanks for following very closely
Jojo at least you're better company than
the doctor was I don't even know what
happened to the doc he's like Vanus was
Leslie after he told me not to fall
and the like an idiot I followed him
obviously knew who ruvik was he had some
actual answers to this whole debacle
maybe I'll have something to go on here
I think I'm just about done smashing
everything getting everything I need
load it up on everything nope lots more
girl your marketplace possessions
somehow always supported the church no
matter what the newspapers said he waved
away the allegations as if they were
infallible the wretched the vermin the
stern while we're taken in by that
church they were promised salvation and
eternal life I think I smell those
things there's nothing like they might
be roasted I couldn't take away uh-huh
okay well then yeah rubiks having fun
over there talking about his family
reminiscing about the good old times you
know
his childhood of probably killing small
animals and not having a good time in
school is it weird to think that you
know if you think back on like every
single character or villain in anything
real-life and video game there had to be
a child at one point and some of them
may have been like messed up children
but all of them at one point had fun and
poop their pants and peed field event
all of them at one point did that like
it's just common between everyone no
matter what it's kind of romantic shut
up Joe Joe I know they're nearby I had
to get all the items
cuz I'm very low on items items is
something that is not a luxury in this
time place come on
okay had to slide up into the door what
do we get oh it's another statute now
that really does look like a statue I've
been breaking for the Joe Joe Joe Joe
what do you suppose we are more like
when this architecture seems straight
out of the Middle Ages yeah but there's
electricity elevators this place can be
real yeah
it's like jumbled up memories yeah the
memories of many many people all in one
it just seems like Jojo can't handle it
but me Sebastian
I've got so many repressed memories and
terrible bad ideas floating around in my
head right this is all probably my doing
it was ply lovely lovely place to be
before I got here don't worry Jojo I'll
protect you no matter the cost
well it's only three as if that's even a
challenge we've killed like hundreds of
them yeah he just wants to care for his
buddy after the accident well I never
put a gun to my head no of course not
just quietly sank into a bottle we can't
all be perfect it never affected my work
okay you read the ia report you know I
didn't report you because I was worried
about your work Sebastian what else is
there hmm turning into a buddy cop movie
and I don't know I came for this I need
my partner here come on partner don't
you quit on me you got it partner
believe believe that you can get better
than you oh we were in a butcher shop
the whole time map fragment it's been
forever that one was just sitting on the
open how hit must have the other ones
been it's all symbols some kind if
occult yeah you're getting it no be
useful yeah you're getting it now he's
into it now that he actually believes
that he can be fine we should probably
get going yeah
you think you're okay because you think
you're okay that's the thing we're in
our minds we have to believe that we're
okay
I can't believe that alcoholic me I
totally called alcoholic by the way
totally new also vampires apparently I
[Music]
want to tell me something here
give me some secret okay no more journal
so straight into the portal of
nightmares oh no it's got to be
something here too these pictures but I
did get another map fragment yeah damn
it yeah I must have missed so many and I
don't know where I would have missed him
plus I'm suddenly gonna get a whole
bunch all at once I don't think that's
the case
oh well yeah if you want a completionist
run-through I'm willing about there's
plenty of people on YouTube that have
done full complete playthroughs or I
would recommend playing yourself this
game is a lot of fun I mean it's
obviously a full-price game it's not
anywhere near an indie game but I'll
admit I've been having fun it's been a
wide range of emotions is that this had
them thoroughly scary moments I mean
it's kind of lingering towards action
more than horror and I mean that's fine
whatever
but I mean they've got these really cool
enemies that they bring out occasionally
when you're like alone in solitude and
right now I'm with a partner so it's
kind of the action moment where he's
trying to help me but either way it's
just it's a lot of fun this game might
be worth the money I'm not trying to
push it on you if you don't want it but
my professional opinion now okay so the
Creasy area of a fact out might be nice
but I don't have enough to give bolts
and I don't think I'm be finding enough
bolt melee damage Oh increased a slight
amount of damage inflicted ones dragging
the enemies
let's do it let's try to punch some sons
of [ __ ] I want to get up to 240
percent male ativ because then I'll
absolutely be able to do a dam in the
face of enemies goddamn Oh enough of all
that we'll get to that in a moment with
more brain juice comes more power I have
a feeling that towards the end of the
game they're just gonna be launching
brains and Sammi left and right I won't
be able to dodge this stuff it'll be
going in my hair and my eyes and my
mouth of my nostrils so let's just
continue up the hill Leslie Leslie I'm
up here and see if I can get a look
ahead that sounds like Leslie good old
buddy Leslie oh there's I would be
amazed if they're just so happened to be
a sniper rifle up there woah peace what
do you see with your elven eyes Jojo Oh
nicole has Liz Lee so where's the doctor
hey that's Kidman that church had the
symbol on it across it's Leslie oh I
called it I called it I called it Oh
totally totally fourth scenario to put
them up in a sniper's roost with a
sniper rifle I don't even know what is
marksmanship smiles are like seems to be
in working condition how amazing don't
shoot me in the back of the head that
would be terrible
oh god no I haven't had something in
mind so long probably make up left over
from yesterday I was wearing makeup now
cuz I was doing a challenge but because
I was doing a shoot whoa okay
so shoot them yay thank you buddy
oh my buddy cops back on the edge again
he's in it to win it
oh oh okay well that's handy that well
that's not handy that so what do I got
oh thank you oh whoa whoa whoa do you
think you're doing that sonny jim thank
you and okay you went down oh go one
down that guy oh that guy dead is he
there we go stomped him out okay so he's
definitely not gonna get up Oh Jojo
you're on the move good I was wondering
when it was so go slowly through here
there's a big pile of meat there that's
really gross
they don't seem to be giving a lot of
items that guy seems to have died in a
horrible situation
oh come on thank you
how about I run how about I run okay
I'll cover you
okay thanks buddy thanks friend get my
shotgun out again woo more shotgun
shells you oh I'm full
really well I better use this then where
is he
whoa there is no don't do that
okay that's bad I know what bad is and
that's exactly it
that looks very bad oh I'm in such
trouble one second it's a freakin ogre
that is literally an ogre oh god I can't
go this way can I pick these up thank
you whew so I need to get him to smash
this I guess show your big ugly face Oh
uncle Marquis poop your big ugly pretty
face so bad no I'm Sebastian um
buddy buddy cop friends
okay thank you thank you body cop I did
not see that guy you definitely helped
me out there
goodness gravy okay so crawl through
here is some goodies
I'm glad how am I supposed to get these
guys down
yay this guy's got a grabby hands I
don't much care for grabby hands can I
get them to fight each other please
Oh God this is bad bad scenarios bad oh
boy oh boy he's gonna grab me hand me I
know it I know he's gonna grab me with
big hands big growth hands I'm gonna
grab and touch all okay well then I'm in
trouble
okay we're fine let's not go back this
way again because that ends poorly for
me is there a way to roll that I don't
know about I need to just keep him out
here oh I did not know there was another
path I was supposed to go okay
that didn't hurt much thankfully it's
pulled me over he's gonna do that again
is he the other ones dead oh I get it
okay no I want the brain juicer with
your gravy oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh god oh god oh no oh no I can't sprint
anymore oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no I
can't even heal because I got the
there's no way I'm gonna be able to get
this in my own time oh wait Oh what okay
I'm just gonna god damn it that was
supposed to be able to get me up to the
point where I can do this again you
wanna help me out there buddy I'm gonna
shoot him in the face maybe
yes I did it I did it all by myself
thankfully and please tell me I actually
got that poo for another route thanks
buddy
you know by the horse statue there he
could jump down at any moment but he
chooses to watch over me like my
guardian eatos only give 3,500 are you
kidding me should I burn them just in
case I don't know 3,500 that's it can I
pick up his mace at least that's kind of
wack people around with it
that'd be fun this is carry on no some
those guys are big they might as well
have been troll beasts okay where was
this horse statue was it over here I
don't quite recall is this okay then
never mind
yeah if I do if I'd actually gotten him
to bust down that door I would have able
to run him in circles but unfortunately
that was not the case so it wasn't over
here I don't think I think it was on the
other side over there must have been
anyway if it wasn't then I'm totally
wrong and I apologize
ho ho I thought it was gonna get up
again alright okay there it is sorry
sorry I had no idea I'm in it hey buddy
that's an interesting horse huh Walt
I've gone to get Donna back I saw how to
get into the Wolf's den and I'm getting
her back I won't let her be a sacrifice
don't follow just stay and watch the
family I'll bring her back
dad wait there was something about a
horse in that house back there uh-huh
let me see what I wrote why would you
have wrote in something written
Rodan what
well fancy that so some other go down
yeah of course into the darkness here we
go again
whoa did not know I was coming back here
why am i back here now I have no idea I
have no idea but I like it
I did get some Juicy Juice good thing my
melee is upgraded that's gonna prove
really effective against the big guys oh
well you know that's good I'm gonna
upgrade melee again because I feel like
it and because if I have good melee then
everyone's gonna want to mail it with me
and that's what's important it's
probably the bit I wish there was a way
to like refund all of your upgrades so
that you could focus on one thing
because I've kind of been split up all
over the place you know I must save
money I'm gonna save on for a big
purchase you never know when you're
gonna need it but I do need to save so
I'm gonna do that though yeah thank you
cuz the chapters not over Oh God with
you no no oh God oh oh okay I can
overwrite there we go okay all right so
that's fine I don't have to delete them
individually so I'm all the time for
this episode so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation momo
videos that i've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]
all around two hours
holy hell got my deep voice it